eins ist uns aufgefallen willi fischer
während dieser diskussion 90 minuten
fußball länge wollen ihn ein foto zeigen
und sie dürfen einmal raten frau fischer
wer das ist wir zeigen ihnen gerade mal
das foto ich hoffe wir sehen uns bei
sich ist ihnen das auch aufgefallen
haben sie gesehen wäre es ist wissen sie
es und bei welchem thema und wer gerade
redete ich dich gesehen
ich habe es leider wirklich nicht
gesehen dass ich hab dir witziger
beobachtet dass sie sich am anfang so
ein papierchen hin und her geschmissen
geschnitzt haben die kann nichts ab das
war nicht aus dem erlös sich ganz auf
das in dem moment war armin laschet
gerade auf seinen handy getippt
immer wieder ist das ganz normal als
ministerpräsident da muss man halt in
den 90 minuten gerade in der schwersten
krise des landes auch erreichbar sein
oder was dem langweilig candy crash
gespielt nein spaß
ich werde natürlich muss man immer
erreichbar sein ich meine man muss aber
auch die priorität dort setzen und sagen
gut ich lege das handy weg können
natürlich auch sagen das war gespickt er
hat sich da von seinem team vielleicht
nochmal wörter reindrängen lassen
ich glaube ich nicht ich glaube wirklich
wenn armin laschet in einem so wichtigen
prägend wie auch sein handy kommt dann
hat das schon tieferen sinn und wird
auch wichtig gewesen sein
der boss macht sagen sie auch wir machen
es ja hier genauso im übrigen ja auch
immer im studio noch kurz aufs handy
gucken passiert irgendwas neues völlig
normal als ministerpräsident oder
scheint ein bisschen langweilig geworden
zu sein
es gab ja durchaus es debatten die
dadurch entschieden wurden weil ja immer
zur falschen zeit auf die uhr guckt also
wie gefährlich kann so was so eine
ungeschickte gestik mimik oder sondern
sommerdebatte auch mal werden
mir ist das aufgefallen mir war das auch
nicht besonders sympathisch ich habe
dafür nur eine erklärung so muss es
gewesen sein
henning krautmacher der sänger der
höhner hat mich angerufen er hätte armin
laschet geschrieben erwarte jetzt auf
eine antwort von ihm und das wird die
antwort gewesen sein dass das dann
leider in der sendung gemacht und wenn
schon digitalisierung ein schwerpunkt
thema des abends war dann wollte am
mittag stellt wahrscheinlich
dokumentieren also wird groß
mit seinem smartphone etwas befremdlich
wenn man das ding überhaupt während
einer solchen debatte auf dem tisch
liegend hat das ist ja das problem
wenn es auf dem tisch liegen hat ist die
versuchung groß damit auch zu arbeiten
also es muss es waldemar hat man
vielleicht noch einmal ganz kurz dazu
ist muss doch 90 minuten während eines
fußballspiels oder nach solchen debatte
eben 90 minuten auch mal ohne handy
gehen sagt wolfgang bosbach wir sind
bild und wir liefern dir deine news auf
youtube zum nächsten video kommst du
hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren